les limites à la croissance on pourrait
croire que c'est le titre d'un manifeste
publié 6 jours-ci dans le cadre de la
COP15 c'était plutôt le vrai titre du
rapport medows publié il y a 50 ans par
le MIT et le Club de Rome un rapport qui
a l'airtait l'opinion publique sur le
fait qu'une croissance infinie mènerait
l'humanité à la catastrophe d'ici la fin
du siècle alors que les ressources de
notre monde elles sont limitées avec
nous pour en parler la cour présidente
du Club de Rome Sandrine Dixon de Clèves
bonsoir madame Dixon de Clèves bonsoir
Pour Tous ne s'en rappelle pas de ce
rapport rappelez-nous d'abord qui en
était les auteurs qui est le Club de
Rome et qu'elle était ce rapport mes
doses
donc en fait les auteurs étaient
effectivement des chercheurs à mit qui
ont été en fait commissionnés demandés
par auréliopathie qui était à ce
moment-là en fait le fondateur de du
Club de Rome et l'idée dans cette
demande c'était de voir effectivement où
on était à ce moment-là concernant en
fait l'économie qui se basait sur une
croissance à l'infini et si avec une
croissance de population et une demande
qui allait croître sur en fait les
ressources naturelles et on vient de
voir les impacts au niveau des minéraux
qu'est-ce qui se passerait et donc il y
a eu plusieurs scénarios qui ont
démontré qu'effectivement en particulier
dans les années 2020 où nous sommes
maintenant on aurait beaucoup d'impact
des crises systématiques qu'on allait
voir que ce soit au niveau de la
biodiversité la disparition en fait des
espèces ainsi que la problématique
autour du changement climatique et donc
voilà 50 ans plus tard nous voyons que
nous sommes face à tous et qui ont été
prédis déjà en 1972 donc le temps vous a
donné raison si on veut madame dexin de
Clèves mais ça avait pas fait
l'unanimité comment ça avait été reçu ce
rapport au départ il y a une
cinquantaine d'années
bien sûr la plupart des politiciens et
des économistes qui croyaient dans un
système ni au libéral et qui voyait en
fait la possibilité du profit de
l'extraction à long terme n'ont pas
voulu écouter quand on est en fait dans
des périodes de croissance économiques
on ne pense pas à l'impact au futur et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que maintenant
nous nous trouvons dans la situation de
de ce qu'on appelle une polycrise avec
plusieurs crises qu'on voit en même
temps la crise du conflit qu'on voit en
Ukraine mais dans beaucoup de pays du
monde aussi bien que la crise climatique
et aussi la pandémie et nous savons que
maintenant nous allons avoir de plus en
plus de crises et que nous devons
maintenant face à justement ces
négociations qu'on a sur la biodiversité
et les négociations qu'on vient d'avoir
sur le changement climatique nous devons
prendre des décisions clés qui changent
en fait la façon dont on interacte avec
notre économie et aussi avec les ce
qu'on appelle en anglais planète
terrible donc la façon dont on utilise
en fait nos ressources naturelles bon
vous avez évidemment bon le clip de Rome
le maït avait publié ce rapport là on
parle de celui de cinquantaine d'années
mais vous en avez publié d'autres depuis
bon par exemple cette année là vous avez
un rapport qui s'intitule heart je
traduis c'est la terre pour tous un
guide de survie pour l'humanité quel est
son message
le message clé de heartford
démontrer que même en fait dans cette
période désespoir et d'anxiété qu'on
ressent parmi beaucoup des citoyens
concernant le changement climatique et
les différentes crises que nous avons
des solutions que nous pouvons en fait
appliquer ce qu'on appelle un scénario
de Giant clip de création en fait
pour en fait changer
où nous sommes maintenant avec des
outils bien précis au niveau de
l'environnement au niveau de l'économie
et au niveau en fait de notre aide
sociale et nous voyons que nous avons
ces outils il faut simplement les
impliquer maintenant cela va nous coûter
d'ailleurs que 3 à 5% de PNB par an au
niveau global donc ça ne va pas coûter
la terre mais si on ne fait rien ça va
nous coûter la terre concrètement madame
dexine de Clèves vont vous vous év
plusieurs scénarios là des grands
chantiers à mettre en oeuvre pour mettre
les sociétés humaines sur une voie plus
durable plus équitable on parle beaucoup
de transition énergétique à notre
émission c'en est un quels sont les
autres
la transition énergétique mais aussi la
transition en fait de l'alimentation du
système de l'alimentation où on change
vers en fait un système régénérateur ou
régénératrice plutôt que le système
alimentaire qu'on a aujourd'hui qui est
purement industriel basé sur que de la
production et beaucoup de déchets il
faut qu'on regarde aussi la pauvreté et
l'initialité et la façon aussi où on met
en fait la femme en plein milieu en
plein milieu pardon des décisions mais
aussi où on est sûr d'avoir de l'accès à
l'éducation parce que beaucoup de femmes
aujourd'hui dans pas mal de pays n'ont
toujours pas en fait d'accès à
l'éducation à l'instruction ne peuvent
ne peuvent pas avoir non plus accès au
pouvoir décidif et ça c'est très
important si on veut aussi diminuer en
fait la croissance au niveau population
est-ce qu'on doit à madame dixing de
Clèves en terminant changer la façon
dont on calcule dont on considère la
prospérité
absolument
absolument nous devons changer la façon
dont on calcule la prospérité et
d'ailleurs on a des exemples et on sait
très bien que le gouvernement de Trudeau
est en train de regarder ces exemples
ces exemples en fait de gouvernance vers
le bien-être ça veut dire que on doit
mettre plutôt en place des indicateurs
qui ne sont pas que des indicateurs de
PNB dont des indicateurs de croissance
mais des indicateurs avec ces
indicateurs de croissance basés sur des
indicateurs sociaux accès par exemple au
médicament accès à les tous les les
services de santé mais aussi des
indicateurs bien clairs au niveau
environnemental donc on a déjà des
gouvernements qui sont en train
d'appliquer en fait cette économie de
bien-être l'Islande l'Écosse le Pays de
Galles ainsi que la Nouvelle-Zélande
donc des exemples desquels on peut
s'inspirer oui madame dexin de Claye je
vais vous arrêter là-dessus c'est tout
le temps qu'on avait mais je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir été là merci
beaucoup au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI